[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships I'm
Dave Ramsey your host Dr John deloney
number one best-selling author host of
the Doctor John deloney show in Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones as we talk to you about you right
in front of you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it Kyle's going to start off this hour
in Indianapolis hey Kyle welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call today
sure what's up
um so essentially I'm 19 years old and
two years ago
um my dad pretty much put himself in a
position where he drank himself to I
don't know if you guys have heard the
term wet brain
um but it's pretty much a vitamin
deficiency and uh
it causes pretty much permanent
short-term memory loss
so now
um that's been going for two years and
were there was a conservatorship and a
guardianship but
we're trying to switch that and we're
not really sure what to do with it
who's we
uh the the whole family
I have two siblings and then TS3
brothers and then my mom is divorced
okay so she hasn't got anything to do
with him she's divorced right
right and so who's got the
conservatorship his brothers
um no it's actually my older brother but
he is like the most irresponsible person
there is so
um my mom pretty much
helps them do it all in fact that really
helps he just she just does it for him
um which we trust our mom but that's
like you said divorce not really
the message would your brother
are are you are you do you want it do
you want conservatorship do you want to
take the lead on some of these decisions
are you just frustrated by the whole
mess
well
I ideally it would be either ideally
it's me because I mean quite frankly I
don't want to tune my own horn but
between his brothers and my siblings I'm
probably the most responsible but I just
I feel like I'm 19 I'm trying to start a
career in real estate I don't really
know yeah right I don't know how much
responsibility it is so a lot a ton yeah
is your dad going to need long-term care
is he able to care for himself in a new
capacity
he's an assistant living right now and I
mean
I don't know how much longer he has
quite frankly because he pretty much
smoke and drank his lungs and liver away
and now he's gained a ton of weight so
I just don't know how long of a
path this is
okay so if assisted living is only 48.
if Assisting Living is caring for his
daily needs
what will the conservator actually be
doing
um there's some paperwork that needs
updated yearly and then
um if you need some of facilities or if
from my understanding if he does pass
away or get close to passing away they
ultimately hold that
um
the responsibility of what happens next
and whatnot so
I can't
um Kyle I can't tell if you are asking
us a question or if you are
wrestling with what about the
conservatorship or if you were just
simply wrestling with
that the unfairness that you should have
to do this yeah that gnarly Paradox
between I love my dad and I want to take
care of him and I can't believe that I'm
in this position
well yeah and that's kind of
the last part of it is that
I think as a family as a whole we all
kind of feel like even if we all were
responsible and we're able to do it
we're kind of just mad at him like
whatever our burden that's fair both and
it is what it is yeah
yeah
I hate that for you I guess and then the
last option would be able to give that
responsibility to the state that
none of us really wants to do that but
at the same time it's been my experience
that if if you're making the choice to
not
um
if you're making the choice to not give
him over to the state then you're making
a choice to be a member of his a part of
his life and if you're choosing to be a
part of his life
those flashes of anger and frustration
that's part of the grieving process
that's normal that's I miss my dad you
and I can't believe he heard himself
like this because his actions now are
going to Ripple through his family for
Generations that's all real and
every moment you choose to dwell on what
happened in the past versus what we got
to deal with what's happening right now
and then what can we make of this and
what happens next in my career in my
life and my education too
is a choice to be miserable in the
present I don't want that for you
do you get what I'm saying so if you
turn him over the state you you dust
your hands off and you walk away okay if
you choose to keep him and every day you
wake up and you're pissed off at him you
are choosing
to have the most miserable road ahead
right yeah so the the the the only way
it would make sense
to move forward I think I'm hearing uh
if you move forward regardless of why
but you have got to commit to
this whole situation not taking up all
of the real estate in your brain
because otherwise you're going to spend
all your time ruminating and dealing
with this and talking about what some
conversation you can't have with a guy
that's not there anymore and so that
involves two things one is it involves
I'm going to very much compartmentalize
this and it's going to get 10 percent
seven percent of my brain to actually
cause the Assisted Living to occur to a
cause hospice to occur later and to plan
a funeral later
um and I and the other thing is I've got
to really get with my pastor and walk
through the process of forgiveness and
set this down so that it doesn't take up
all of your brain
if it takes up all of your brain it's it
is completely unfair to you and I would
I would turn if you cannot do that and I
don't know if I could have at 19 Kyle
but if you cannot if you cannot do that
then you need to also clear your brain
by letting someone else do it other than
you
you do not have a moral or ethical
responsibility to take this on at 19.
you have the option to do it but you do
not have the
the Mandate from scripture or Society
for a 19 year old to fix his dad who
drove drunk himself into the point of
being an invalid and in fact legally
your brother has that responsibility
right now right now nope yeah your
brother has it legally but you don't
have the the
weight of you have to do this or you're
a bad guy that's not there
[Music]
so the only way you can move forward is
if you set enough of this aside that
you're that you still have more than
enough room to have a great life in your
brain and sometimes the best thing you
can give your dad is to take care of
yourself and to get about living your
life to sorry you're fishing this hun
yeah it's hard man this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more firsts
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five it is next in
Tampa Florida hey Ed welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey gentlemen how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so I got a real estate question
um I am 26 my wife's 26 and we are about
to purchase our first home awesome to
purchase our first home that is
um and got pre-approved recently and I'm
struggling with understanding what what
to do here so uh they I was quoted for
putting 20 down on a home and 15 down on
a home
and on a 15-year fixed and my rate for
20 down is higher than my rate
if I put 15 down that makes no sense and
I don't I agree and that's what I'm
trying to figure out why that would be
and which direction I should go you
should talk to Churchill Mortgage and
get a quote and then ask them if they
give you the same thing that's uh why in
the flip is this because I I know of no
logical reason that should occur
as a matter of fact when you put 20
anointment are you dealing with an FHA
loan or a conventional loan
conventional okay with 20 down you will
avoid PMI private mortgage insurance
which will amount to about uh three
quarters of a point I mean it'll amount
to a lot
right it's about seventy five dollars
per hundred thousand borrowed per month
yep and um and so not having that with
twenty percent down is a substantial
savings
I mean it's like 200 bucks a month if
you're borrowing 300 Grand
and the rate should be the interest rate
should be exactly the same either way
but putting less down would normally
cause you to have a higher interest rate
because it is a higher risk for the
mortgage company that's
that's what that's what I would have
thought yeah and they said that
the the lender that that I was so were
the new developed new community being
developed so it's the preferred lender
of the Builder oh whoopee
so I mean I prefer not to use this
lender yeah
so there's not the preferred lender of
the buyer on the same boat yeah no
kidding
yeah I think I don't I I don't know what
they're doing I honestly have no idea
did they they give you no logical
explanation for the higher rate
uh basically what she said is that when
someone puts 20 down and the bank is no
longer charging them PMI they still view
that as a higher risk than if someone
put 15 down and they do charge them PMI
well that's just not true
okay because the whole purpose of the
the reason PMI is there when you put
less down is because it's higher risk
that's why they make you get it
private mortgage insurance pays the bank
if they lose money in the event they
have to foreclose on you it does not
insure you in any way it ensures them
against you
getting foreclosed on in them losing
money that's what PMI does there is no
PMI at 20 down and the reason is
industry standard is is the very
unlikely to lose money so Ed I'm going
to ask Dave a question is it Dave is
there a possibility that
because I think there's a profit motive
here is what it is right so is there a
possibility that or actually at risk
that when you're over 20 and you ask for
your PMI by law they've got to take it
off but then they no longer are insured
against that loan they don't they do not
have insurance without PMI on a
conventional loan there's no insurance
so it sounds like this mortgage company
is saying we don't want to do loans that
aren't insured no that because they're
selling the stinking loan it's a Fannie
Mae loan it's it's all it's going to be
bundled up anyway yeah they're going to
be bundled up and sold on the secondary
market so they're it's it's a it's weird
man yeah it's a con it's a conforming
loan it conforms to a set of guidelines
so that it can be bundled and sold and
so I I think it's a local uh mortgage
company that thinks he's got a fish in a
barrel because you're buying this on a
new site and and they're the preferred
lender okay I prefer not to get
overcharged so I'm going to prefer to
use somebody else check Churchill and
see if you can find out what's going on
there may be something I don't know here
but I don't think so I mean I've been
doing real estate for 40 years so
um this is weird it's very weird that
yeah and if you have the 20 down I would
put the 20 down rather than pay the
extra 200 a month per 300 000 borrowed
for PMI that gives you absolutely zero
benefit so uh that's why we suggest 20
down on a first time home buyer we
lighten up and go oh if you want to do 5
or 10 or 15 that's okay because it gets
you into the house but the downside is
you're going to be biting the bullet on
that PMI but I mean that's a lot of
money so it makes no sense at all Scott
um I mean you're you're I mean I'm sorry
you're you're you're asking the right
questions and uh the best way to to do
to keep people honest is get another bid
so go to Churchill Mortgage talk to them
and um they can take care of you in
Tampa for sure they've been an
Advertiser with us for 30 years and uh
that team Mike Hardwick and that team do
a great job hey man thank you for
calling in I wish it was easy but it's a
good I wish I knew the answer I don't I
don't I don't but I agree with you on
the frustration I think you're getting
the run around some way or another but
maybe there is something I don't don't
know keep keep pushing till you learn
Scott's with us in Milwaukee Wisconsin
hey Scott
hey uh Dave and John thank you thank you
for taking my call sure how can we help
so I'm on uh babysit baby step two uh I
have 136
000 in student loans
um and was wondering if using the equity
I have in my house to in about four or
five years down the road uh either
refinance or uh take out a HELOC uh to
pay off that student loans when uh it
becomes an option
well I you didn't pay off the student
loan you just moved it on to your home
if you don't pay a student loan they
don't even knock that around yeah if
they don't if they don't uh if you don't
pay a student loan they don't foreclose
on your house or if you don't pay a
HELOC they foreclose on your house
you just increase your risk yeah you
just put your house on the line for your
stupid student loan no thank you
sure even like refinancing to uh to a
15-year well again you just you just put
your house on the line for the student
loan you didn't pay it off dude you just
moved it you understand right yep and
you pay it off means that you don't owe
it anymore anywhere you moved it with
more risk yeah yeah so what's your
household income
uh about a hundred cool good for you how
old are you
uh 33 and four kids good for you she
stay at home mom full-time or what
uh no she works part-time so what's your
total household income
a hundred oh with a hundred includes her
okay
yeah how old are the kiddos
uh uh one for
11 and 12. what do you do for a living
a physical therapist
good for you you paid a lot for that if
that whole if that's if that's true
that's all you want you got here you got
hammered okay
um
most pts I know are making more than 80
000 a year what's is it your Market
what's it just started uh just started
okay I bet didn't you
yeah so base salary of about uh 70 uh
when did you start and I work I work
weekends when did you when did you get
out when did you get your PT
2018 so about three and a half years now
yeah okay yeah you're gonna you're but
John's right you're gonna you should see
ten thousand dollar bumps along the way
here pretty quick as you get some
experience and you got the ability to
add some hours except for the fact you
got a bunch of Littles at home but the
uh uh yeah tear into this thing I want
you to just get you just roll up your
sleeves and go bust your butt stay out
of restaurants no vacations and get this
thing knocked out and then when your
house is paid off it's paid off you
didn't have those big butt student loan
over there hiding behind your mortgage
acting like it didn't happen it's a form
of financial denial uh so no I I and I'm
gonna help you Scott I've been right
where you are and didn't know what to do
it's we've got the answer it's called
Financial Peace University
and if you'll hang on I'm going to pay
for it for you and your wife and your
four littles and I want you to go
through this class just nine lessons and
we're gonna Jack you up Jazz you up and
teach you what to do and if you'll go do
exactly what we teach you should have
this paid off in about three years
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Jake and Kate are with
us hey guys how are you hi Dave doing
great great happy to be here honored to
have you where do you live Cleveland
Ohio oh I love it I love it good to have
you guys how much debt have you paid off
we paid off 223 thousand thirty four
dollars and 16 cents wow how long did
this take this took us 36 months wow and
your range of income
started at 70 went up to about a hundred
thousand to to 200 000. okay that works
but what do you guys do for a living
I'm a safety manager for a uh local
government
and my wife
um I'm a director of operations
marketing moving into events ah very
good but I also have a um a side hustle
a construction company which that's what
took that from the 100 to 200 whoa so
you're making more money on side hustle
than the whole stinking deal yeah yeah
good for you guys yeah well done when
you show up to uh do safety inspections
do you say I'm from the government and
I'm here to help
well we know that doesn't work so all
right just wondered what kind of debt
was the 223 or yeah 223 000. we had two
vehicles
um we had uh a few credit cards
um my school loans and we paid off our
house
okay how much of the 233 was the
mortgage
uh 70 000. yeah no so student loans with
a big dog yeah 126 in school loans oh
wow wow what happens when the student
loan is larger than the mortgage you're
not
good for you guys
come on well done how long you been
married
11 years yeah 11 years I'll catch them
first on that one
picture
that was nice that was very short it'll
be 12 years we are on TV so yeah and the
um on May the fourth the uh close so
what happened three years ago then
because you guys have been doing this
the other way for a long time yeah Dave
um well well first of all I want to I
want to mention that the uh the what's
important about the date today is 22
years ago to the day today is when I
started dating my bride wow and uh and
and so who would have the irony of that
that we would be in this journey along
the way that we'd be back you know and
and be on the stage and be able to share
our story yeah
um and we didn't pick that date it was
assigned to us so kind of crazy just
yeah
well the people in the booth they do
detailed research on people and they
found that they Googled and found that's
when you started dating no I'm kidding
yeah cool I'm glad it worked out yeah
but but the big but the really the the
um reason is is our little fella here to
the right Jackson
um is uh our son is really what what
ignited us for us okay so he's three
he's three correct ah okay so kid comes
and you go whoa just got real boom yep
yep and we got after it we realized that
you know we wanted we we live in a nice
Community but we want to get to
somewhere where we can really put him in
the in another Community where he was
good for him growing up for school and
um
um I mean that's just been on our minds
so we said you know what we got to do
this now we have got to get after this
right now so get after it we we set up
you get plugged into Ramsay yeah we we
actually did Financial Peace University
at a church
um our teachers Jorge and uh Kayla Pena
up in Cleveland Ohio yeah
um instructed us
um we started in September I mean we
were bringing him to class when he was
three weeks forward weeks old yeah but
Jake started a while back he started in
2010 after we got engaged I was trying
to get the ball moving yeah I actually I
took it in Orlando Florida when I was
living in Orlando and then they shipped
me to a job site and I was trying to do
it more so face time and that wasn't
working out okay are you holding him
back a little bit it was because I had
the answers what I was doing is what I
know and was comfortable so you know I
didn't want to be uncomfortable yeah
that's funny we were just talking about
just talking about that yeah yeah Wow
way to go you guys way to go I'm proud
of you how's it feel to be free house
and everything you weirdos it's it's
it's surreal it really is we're like
the house looks nicer it looks shinier
like it feels good it's ours I mean when
I looked when we paid that house off
made that last payment I was looking at
the the ceiling you know in the house
and I'm like it's just it was a
different look it was like man this is
mine now you know and
um God's calling us to something greater
and it's not so much about ourselves
we've taken care of that so now we can
provide for us you've got no payments in
the world and you can be outrageously
generous that's right I know that's very
very very cool so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
well I think I think the one thing Dave
huge is is the budget and really
um getting on a a plan
um we still do our every dollar app
where the every dollar on the app and
and we still have weekly and daily
meetings I would tell her hey we went
over in this area we get you know we we
gotta we gotta cut this back you know
next month or you know this month
whatever so
um staying on that budget not letting no
not getting distracted by outside noise
you know there's a lot of people that
had their views on how you should do
this and how you do that we were focused
on the goal and we went after that and
um you know that's we we knew what we
the end goal what we wanted to get to
and and not be afraid to take on a side
hustle yeah I mean I I started this this
construction business from the ground up
and I just went after it and
you know like I said just kept kept the
the mind on the target you know so are
you running this construction business
with cash yeah I I paid my dump truck my
trailer all my equipment it's all Cash
There's No debt in the business way to
go you are so far ahead of the game on
that one wow incredible what's the house
worth
uh 220 000. yeah and how old are you
guys I'm 39. I'm gonna think about it
38. 38 39 so you're not even 40. 100
debt free and so easily 45 years old
you're going to be net worth
millionaires easy well you know another
um part of the journey you know the the
the Think and Grow Rich that I've been
you know they brought that definite
purpose that would that's that's part of
being want to be a millionaire by 45 so
yeah you're going to be there I'm not
the goal the math says you're going to
be there yeah great way to go guys so
proud of you well done hey we've got to
live and give bundle for you that's The
Total Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book both number one best
sellers enjoy them or give them away and
then a membership to Financial Peace
University since you've been through it
you'll probably be giving that away and
let's bring Mr three-year-old Jackson up
so he can enjoy the dead three scream
with his mom and dad quick note on this
little guy he um also is an inspiration
because we had quite the fertility
journey to get him so God has blessed us
immense nicely so we're pumped to give
back and and we can't wait to celebrate
with him and he does look like a
blessing
beyond measure right well done well done
all right Jackson Kate and Jake
Cleveland Ohio 223
000 paid off in 36 months making 70 to
100 to 200 house and everything
everything 40
. they're weirdos counted down let's
hear a debt free scream okay three two
one we're dead friends yeah yeah
[Applause]
I love it well done you guys
that little Jackson has no idea of how
much of a hero his mom and dad are no
but they have changed his life in ways
he has no concept of yet he's gonna miss
out on being the ringside seat too some
knockdown drag outs because they won't
have them yeah they won't be having the
money fights the number one cause of
divorce in North America today and more
than the money fight is the money simmer
that tension that just stays in your
house all the time that then fights
erupts from right now the constant
boiling just below it makes everybody
feel crazy yeah and you go what's wrong
in here what's wrong I feel it I can't
feel it in the air and I grew up in that
and yeah most people do yeah most of us
do like it's that's the air we breathe
growing up and developing our brains and
our bodies and he's not going to have
that and then we wonder why we're
anxiety ridden in this culture and then
your dad's gonna give you a sledgehammer
and say get to work son you're gonna be
way ahead of the ball game brother
shovel shovel out the shovel at the dump
truck there you go there you go I like
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsay show
Jordan is next in Greenville South
Carolina hi Jordan welcome to the show
hey how's it going better than I deserve
what's up
hey yeah so or wonder if I can have some
Financial advice here uh I'm a traveling
nurse making a decent amount of money
um and I was having a conversation with
my girlfriend last night and she'd
mentioned that she had Roth IRA and she
has about 15 000 and after about two and
a half years uh although she didn't know
too much information about it her dad
kind of helped set her up
um I I make about 2400 a week after
taxes
um and I'm just throwing it into savings
and I don't know if I should be throwing
it into somewhere else or what I can do
to set myself up to be more successful
in the future good for you good for you
how old are you
I'm 28 to 29 in April excellent good
work okay well uh do you have any debt
uh I have a truck uh it's about forty
thousand uh or right now it's about 38
000 and then student loans total about
60. okay
I would tell you to clean those up
before you start your long-term
investing and clean them up really fast
because you just started travel nursing
and you started making bank and so quit
acting like you make it throw it all at
these debts
because you got a hundred thousand
dollars in debt hanging around your neck
right and yeah getting rid of that in in
the next two three years would be like
the most powerful thing you could do to
build wealth that would be your first
step then when you finish that the next
thing we teach people to do is build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses we call that baby step three
the next baby step is baby step four and
so at this point we're probably
um
you know two to three years from today
okay because you're doing these other
things first then you start putting 15
of your income into retirement at baby
step four now that would be a Roth IRA
and are you paid on 10.99
I am yes sir okay so you're
self-employed so you qualify for another
thing called a SEP IRA which as of this
year you can also do as a Roth you can
do a regular individual Roth IRA and you
can do a SEP IRA and I would tell you to
put those all in good growth stock
mutual funds and if you click at
ramseysolutions.com you can meet with a
smart investor which are Brokers for
mutual funds financial advisors that
don't work for me but they do the stuff
the way I teach so you're going to get
advice consistent with what you're
hearing me say and hearing us say here
at Ramsey and they'll help you get
everything set up and get that going
when it's time but you can save a lot of
money and if you don't have any payments
it'd be easier to save money agreed
agreed yes sir um I I was questioning
the paying off the truck as far as
traveling my my plan was to just traded
in every couple of years because I need
something with reliability if I'm going
to be traveling
um it's pretty much going to guarantee
your broke your whole life
okay doing that okay understood so let
me help you with this if you're
traveling and you're using an expensive
vehicle to travel in whatever you drive
at 40 or 50 000 miles a year you are
destroying its value
right
and so how much do you want to destroy
sixty thousand or twenty thousand
I understood and so if you trade up into
sixty thousand dollar trucks every three
years and start the destruction process
again actually the truck isn't destroyed
you just destroyed its value because 120
000 120 000 mile 150 000 mile truck by
the time you get ready to roll it over
after three years
um you know you you just pull it up on
um Kelly Blue Book and see what they do
the miles just just tank the value and
so you've got to do you've got to this
is your overhead in your business travel
is your overhead and you want to
minimize overhead to maximize profits
and so you need to drive the least
expensive vehicle for travel nursing
that if you want to leave the truck the
driveway it's okay but you need to drive
the least expensive vehicle for travel
nursing that'll get the job done get the
job done means you get there because
it's reliable and you don't have to go
to the chiropractor because you weren't
driving a smart car
I mean so you gotta have something
reasonable but you do not have to have
and should not be driving a 65 000
vehicle when you're a road warrior I I
just am imagining the conversation he's
gonna need to have he might need to take
his wife out to a nice day this is a
girlfriend the girlfriend and sit down
and say you were dating a truck guy
you're now dating a camera guy and uh
dropping a used Honda guy yeah yeah
driving an old Accord telling you you
get a Camry or a Honda Accord that's got
you know Outlast you it's two years old
and you pay you know you pay 15 20 000
bucks for it you run that puppy in the
dirt and if you want a nice truck that's
okay just leave it in the driveway
because you're not because you're just
freaking hammering it on value and uh so
and just I'm gonna trade every so often
means you're just increasing the amount
of dollars that you're losing not to
mention I mean you pick the vehicle with
the worst gas mileage you can imagine
too right if you're driving all over
creation with them yeah anyway yeah I
agreed yeah I think you know
but nice truck yeah it's a cool truck
man it's cool trucks oops Yeah I just
called about the IRA please don't sell
my truck so sold it's gone the lesson
here is never ask financial advice for
your girlfriend that's that's the meta
here
I think she sets you up why don't you
call Dave and see what he says boom RAV4
Matthew is in Nashville hey Matthew how
can we help
hey Uncle Dave hey Dr John deloney how
are you doing guys great brother what's
up
uh quick question is uh me and my fiance
are about to get married here in June
yeah we are we're going to combine our
finances at that point good we are both
debt free she has 20 000 in her savings
gonna have I have just close to a
hundred thousand a mine good uh we are
set free of course and we're wondering
if uh it's a safe time to buy even
though the housing market has gone up
substantially it's going to continue to
go up
so every year you wait it's going to be
more
right obviously we had 20 percent down
yeah you got great down yeah
um our month our
income for the whole year is roughly
about 120. good for you you guys are
doing so good man way to go good start
well I mean you got two options one is
you can buy after you get married uh two
is you could rent for six months
and then Dr start looking and buy that's
actually has nothing to do with the
economy or the real estate market that's
actually wiser because it takes about
six months to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy
mm-hmm you got to get you you'll buy a
different house six months after
marriage than you would buy six days
after marriage
because you get to know each other
better and you get to figure out that
whatever she wants she's going to get
you get to figure out these things right
correct yeah we've been together for
seven years doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
does it matter when you were married
that's when it changes yeah correct
correct she's gonna be real close to
those I I would continue to pile up cash
and rent for six months and spend all of
my energy being a newlywed not looking
for houses or hanging curtains
okay yeah currently our lease earns in
October so it might be okay that's not
quite sure that's not quite six months
but you know start looking uh in August
and September and find something to move
into in October yeah and Matthew I live
in your in your city and I'd I'd buy a
place tomorrow if my wife needed to move
I wouldn't think twice about it as far
as the economy goes economically yeah
yeah and or the price of housing or
whatever it's not going to go down man
there's a shortage of Housing and so uh
yes I know interest rates are up yes I
know the economy sucks yes I know eggs
are more than gold I understand all that
but housing is not going down in value
still not because things things go up or
down in value based on simple Supply
demand economics and we have a shortage
of housing not an oversupply
when I go down is when you have an
oversupply
and we do not have that Builders have
Frozen like during headlights quit
building like crazy Builders or I'll
stand around looking at each other going
let's have coffee and even the builders
are waiting on stuff to show up and
supplies and no windows and no wood and
all that stuff still yep still shortage
shortage shortage shortage and um the
economy slowed down but the buyers
slowed down too and so yeah you're
you're fine I I would buy in October is
what I would do good question and
congratulations sir hold on we're gonna
put you guys through Financial Peace
University as our wedding gift for you
guys and uh that way you know in a few
years you'll be like baby steps
Millionaires and you can blame Dr John
deloney for that and uh you're going
it's all because of Dr Joe I'll take
that blame man there you go hey guys uh
we got our live Building Wealth live
events coming up starting next week
February 16th will be in Indianapolis
Austin Texas February 23rd Salt Lake
City April 24th in Anaheim on May 2nd
tickets are only 49 and your four
packets starting as low as 175 dollars
check out the tickets at
ramseysolutions.com events uh it's all
of the Ramsey Personalities in different
ones of us albeit every one of them come
out we'd love to have you this is the
Ramsay show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the pots moving and storage and Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jeremy
is in Martinsburg West Virginia
hi Jeremy how are you good afternoon
good afternoon thank you so much for
having me on sure how can I help
so my question regarding some Financial
anxiety that I'm going through I married
my
in my 2020 and we've been on fire we
paid off 90 000 in debt and last summer
we just paid off our house
and you're probably thinking where's the
anxiety coming from and I guess I was
expecting like an office space moment
where I've got Financial Freedom and you
know carries no worries and what I'm
finding out is when I paid off the house
I went the bank account went from 230
000 down to 50 000 and it just had me
kind of shook I'm not sure
what steps I should be doing and I'm
afraid to even move at this point
so your anxiety is because you have less
money in your account
I'm afraid to be I'm afraid to be wrong
like I know where we came from with the
90 000 in debt and I'm afraid I don't
know what to do with it like where to
move I know 97 000 included paying off
your mortgage or that on top your
mortgage on top of that
a little on top of that 90 000 was uh
just regular debt and then how much was
the mortgage how much the mortgage of
185 000. okay so 275 000 has been paid
off since the covid quarantine Andrew
got married
correct and you didn't die
correct
a lot of stress what do you do for a
living
I'm a federal contractor God Almighty
kind of feels like you've been running
with your hair on fire for three years
and you finally just don't have anything
to be on fire about and it scared you
correct yes so here's a weird thing I
wish it wasn't the case man but here's
our bodies solve for the nerd word is
homeostasis it likes the way things have
always been
and that's why when somebody knocks off
50 or 60 or 70 pounds
if they haven't made an entire
environment change change their life
change their identity I am now somebody
who does X Y or Z their body will
scratch and Claw that 50 60 70 pounds
back on because that's what it knows
and your body knows fight or flight run
War it's all coming down
it has never practiced peace peace and
so dude you're not crazy you're not nuts
your anxiety alarms are ringing off the
hook as they should be because you are
in Uncharted water you just don't know
what to do when when you're not when the
water's not dumping over the side of the
boat when it's just calm and chill
and it's just it's gonna be a season
you're gonna have to practice and you
have to learn how to be still not create
chaos because there's none being created
for you right
right and it sounds like uh I know what
I'm talking about because this is the
pot talking to the kettle it's good to
meet you man
yeah I mean
you do think about I wasn't kidding
around what all you did
in the beginning of a pandemic and out
the back end of a quarantine and a
pandemic when when we were all an
unprecedented oh God I hate that word
um now uh uh stress levels
and in the middle of that you went ahead
and got married
so let's add some stress in the middle
of that you went ahead and paid off 275
000 and completely revolutionized your
life which means you turned up the
burners to the highest possible Heat
um while you were in all of these other
burners and the water was already
boiling and all of a sudden it all just
went off and got quiet
that makes sense
yeah I think I'm just looking to find
out what I should be doing now I guess I
guess I know investing but we both have
lost Ira she has attention so I'm just
I'm not sure what to do now I don't know
what to do just breathe chill that's it
you start investing and being
outrageously generous you're 100 debt
free
make snow angels in your front yard
what's your what's your household income
D before tax with no payments
right take your shoes off and go walk
around the backyard that grass is yours
now all that crap you used to pay
payments on let's take those payments
and put them in Investments
fill up your 401k fill up your Roth
fill up your envelope This Is Random
Acts of generosity
and catch the single mom pumping gas
with the kids with The Frayed clothes
and our tires are bald as a baby's butt
roll the car over to the car
tire place next door and put four tires
on her car and fill it up and have the
oil changed and pay cash for it and
smile and walk away and she'll never
know who did it because you're God's
angel that day because you now have
money
how's that sound
sounds great here's a common thing that
happens is we think and and again like
getting out of debt is a is a core tenet
of not being anxious
but we often forget that wherever we end
up we go with us
and so
if you thought there was going to be
some magic wand that suddenly you were
going to like yourself or suddenly you
were gonna not have any more shame from
when you were a kid or suddenly your dad
was gonna call you and tell you how
proud he was and that call ain't coming
being debt free will set you free from
anybody any external change that got you
but it may be now you can do the work
that you need to do to heal right stuff
you've been crap you've been carrying
around for a long long time yeah that's
that's possible it gets really quiet
then the voices kick up exactly it's
it's like uh you've experienced this I
have and I've just met with countless
couples who's the last kid moves out and
that house gets quiet and now we got to
learn how to have a new kind of life
because it's different now
you know we plan so intentionally that
the party just began when they left
[Laughter]
somebody yeah my mom carrying a disco
ball into the house is he really gone
oh hey let's let's like just full
disclosure
you and I I've asked you off air
as my life has transitioned since I've
taken this job
like I I there's this there's a this
there's a discomfort with the newness of
not running for my life anymore and not
feeling like the whole world's coming
down being able to love my wife and not
being panicked in the middle of the
night when she's asleep six o'clock go
home we don't work at seven yeah go home
here you know that's there there's it's
an intentional act but the thing is it's
just I said this other thing with Megan
Kelly I was on her podcast if you want
to turn it on guys she's got a great
podcast on our podcasters they say
making a slack if you're driving down
the road at 100 miles an hour and then
you slow down to 55 it seems like you're
crawling and she goes not an experience
I've ever had Dave
you haven't either
yeah I never slowed down to 55. now she
sucks but she never got up to 100.
she's a law-abiding citizen
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today
hey guys we have about 25 million of you
out there between YouTube and podcast
and radio and TBN watching and listening
and so forth to this show and uh 100 of
you came to us because someone told you
about us or you stumbled into us not
because we did some big marketing
campaign because um we're not Sofi we're
not financing a stadium
so
um or buying expensive
um Super Bowl ads or anything like that
the way that you can help us if we've
been a blessing to you is you can tell
other people about the show so share it
click it uh if it's uh you know if
you're you're on YouTube or something
like that you've got a share function uh
subscribe to the show follow the show
whatever's appropriate in your setting
if you're listening on talk radio uh put
it in your memory on your radio so that
you can reach and push that memory
button and always find that station at
this time of day and listen to us thank
you for that and uh where you have the
option to leave a review a five-star
review nothing else is helpful mama said
if you ain't got nothing nice to say
don't say nothing at all so leave a five
star review or just don't bother you're
not any help so uh Spread spread the
love man that's that's what makes this
thing happen around here and we
appreciate you guys a lot hey taxes are
confusing I hate them I'm perpetually
grouchy this time of year if you want to
buy some tax services out there
you can think you're never going to get
a grasp on taxes they tell you how dumb
you are we think you're smart you have
two choices for claiming tax deductions
and understanding the difference that
can save you can save you big bucks you
can either take the standard deduction
or itemize your deductions both options
lower your tax bill but which one's best
and that depends on your tax situation
so let's take a closer look the standard
deduction is easy no-brainer
it subtracts the set amount from your
taxable income based on your filing
status let's say you're single you make
sixty five thousand the standard
deduction knocks off about thirteen
thousand dollars so you pay taxes only
on fifty two thousand it's like an
automatic write-off
itemizing deductions deductions in that
case would only work if you had
deductions greater than thirteen
thousand which mean you gave to your
church or you had something else that
was a tax deduction that added up to
more than thirteen thousand dollars so
for more help in making sense of all
your income taxes and filing with
confidence go to ramseysolutions.com tax
that's
ramsesolutions.com slash tax Jeff is in
Canada hi Jeff welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Jeff uh sorry I uh
um yeah hi hi how can we help what's up
man
um
so I'm in a pretty bad buying uh I
screwed up and uh now I'm about
give or take 37 000 in debt living pay
the check the paycheck
and a good part of my debt is actually
my old business and more specifically my
old employees
um I haven't been sleeping well for a
while now and I just I want to get out
of this
I want to honor them
although I haven't done it for the last
few years but I just want to fix
everything
and uh yeah
wow you've been hit with a lot so you've
got the uh
I mean I closed a business and went
broke so I know how that feels it you
feel ashamed on top of that I didn't pay
my bills or my bankrupt so I felt double
ashamed and on top of that you've got
employees that you love that you owe
money to so you got another dose of
Shame uh so you you've got a lot hanging
on your shoulders don't you
yeah
um
I decided to fight to not go bankrupt by
purpose because I knew I well you're
gonna pay them anyway because they're
your friends
pardon you're going to pay them anyway
because they're your friends even if you
went bankrupt right
most of them were my friends until
um sorry
um
and
I'm
it's just getting worse and worse and
what do you make what do you make now
uh right now I work remote uh for 2400 a
month
well that sucks uh take home uh take
home so that's with the deductions yeah
that sucks
um
but I had a second job earlier this
winter but I was uh I was uh I laid off
and I can't get a second job I've been
hunting for one day
um I don't have a car anymore because
part of my bed is also blocking my
license from from me being able to
travel so I can travel but I can't I
need a car because I live in the real
rural area
so part of the part of the settlement
against your debt is that you can't go
get work somewhere else that doesn't
make any sense
it's like an old debtor's prison back
from the Dark Ages
and our Province if you owe anything for
traffic tickets and some of those
traffic tickets were from our old bus
and my old drivers and me had signs and
the owner of the company gets a fine as
well as a driver if there's anything
wrong even if it's speeding the owner of
the company gets a fine as well all
right
okay so you
you're talking to two guys who in
various stages have been right where you
are
okay
and so the question I'm going to ask you
on behalf of both of us is first I'm
going to say
it feels like everything is in a dark
cloud
absolutely you're not crazy
the question I'm going to ask you is
this
do you want to do what it takes
to begin scratching and clawing and
sprinting your way out of this thing
I've been trying to because I went for a
second job earlier no I got you I got
you but but part of saying yes I want to
scratch and Claws saying okay the way I
was doing it wasn't working I want to
try something else
would you be willing to do that
yeah okay you've got two issues here one
is and you have in your mind they've all
turned into one big toxic stew
one of the issues is you got to get
these debts paid off
the second is yeah like so it's a math
problem you got a finance issue and the
second thing is is you've got so much
shame so much relationship dysfunction
now you're working from home so you just
sit by yourself all day long it's still
it's doing students do and you faced
rejection and you got laid off all this
stuff so you got this interpersonal
stuff going on this relationship stuff
right so these are two separate
challenges here so we got a plan for you
to help you with the money
but you're gonna have to take someone I
would consider some pretty radical steps
on The Human Side of this would you be
willing to do that
yeah and I I forgot to say earlier that
I've been looking at getting uh loan
to try and to tackle one of the two
and just get rid of one of the two
problems main problems
um so I was also calling about that if I
should get along and fight for it no you
have an income problem
we have to solve that we have to solve
your income problem you can't borrow
your way out of debt
and the bad news is you have 37 000
worth of debt the great news is it's not
370 000 it's only thirty seven thousand
dollars three thousand dollars a month
for a year and you're free
you're completely free but you don't
make any money
and you've got a thousand reasons why
you have to stay in this
poop that you're sitting in and I'm
going to tell you you probably need to
move to another city and get six jobs in
the city
and that you can't sit in a rural
community where there's no jobs and make
twenty four hundred dollars in a dark
room and get out of this
besides that you need the human
interaction you need the sunlight
yeah yeah and you need a new look a new
a new a fresh start
and I don't know if you moved back to
this community someday later but I want
you to go 100 miles away and move into a
major city and I want you to work seven
jobs 80 hours a week and I want you to
be a hundred percent debt free by this
time next year with fifteen thousand
dollars in the bank then you've got some
choices
but you've got to do something radical
to get your income up your income is
horrible horrible
I'm picking on you I'm just telling you
math isn't you don't get a pass on that
you got to push your way through this
and it's going to require John asked you
are you willing to do what it takes I
just told you what it takes it's what
you need to do
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America this is the
Ramsey Show open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Mark is
in Joplin Missouri hey Mark welcome to
the show
today what are y'all up to just
struggling through man how can we help
I understand hey me and my wife here
we're kind of quick and tweening a lot
of stuff and we was needing to ask a
question okay
we're twitched and clean step five and
six and our gazelle he's kind of sitting
in the thicket there catching his breath
a little bit and we was wondering which
way to point him and how hard to kick
him
well you got it dialed in man I like it
well what we tell folks is you do
gazelle intensity which is scorched
Earth no life a hundred percent game on
in baby steps one through three so when
I tell you what we have crossed and you
did that the Prairie you did that yeah
you got through and now uh now you've
got your emergency fund in place and
you're debt free and you're doing baby
steps four five and six simultaneously
and we tell folks when you go when you
do that we uh we do sideline the gazelle
uh we move from intense to intentional
right from a Sprint to a marathon
we're still running our girls are yeah
our girls are fixing to get out of
school and May and we'll have them
through school so they'll be done with
that got them off the page
yeah they're they'll be done off the
payroll and gone good and basically we
got about 170 000 left on our farm and
then we'll then we'll be done done yeah
and so intentional looks intentional
looks like this yes if you need to
upgrade your couch that's going to slow
down the paying down on the farm by the
amount of the couch yes we're gonna go
on vacation mama needs one and uh that's
gonna slow down the paying down on the
farm but we're not going to consume so
many things that we don't do anything
towards getting rid of that farm debt
but we're also not doing beans and rice
rice and beans gazelle intensity at this
stage and having no life this is the
stage where we have a life but we're
careful about it and intentional so that
we still accomplish those other goals as
well so you move from intense to
intentional
that sounds that sounds better than what
we've been doing
but hey here's the thing Mark you you're
gonna have to practice it because you're
not going to be any good idea we ain't
really used we ain't really used to it
no cause that means here's what it means
in the past for the past few years you
don't have a conversation about the
couch and just know we're paying off
debt now you and your wife gonna have to
have a conversation about a couch and
that's a skill set that most married
couples don't have and so we're going to
practice it we're going to practice
where do you want to go for vacation how
big is it going to be and how small is
it going to be you're going to spend on
that the less we can put on the farm
that's right and there's an expect some
tension there if you don't have tension
something's weird you're gonna have
tension there and that's part of the
deal you will always have tension
because you always have a limited amount
of money
no one has unlimited money and an
unlimited amount of I wish we could yeah
there's always a there's always a list
and it's always longer than the money
um and so it doesn't matter and it's
like the list does get more fun of
course because the stuff on it is much
cooler when you've got some money but uh
it's still a list and there's still some
things we're going to do right now and
some things we're not going to do right
now and you got to make those four
forced ranked decisions as a couple
there's I I wonder Dave if it's just
sometimes easier I I I've never thought
of this I'm thinking saying it out loud
so catch me if I'm wrong here but in
some ways it's easier just to take off
running just a scorched Earth it does
because it's it's simple it's singular
focused and so you don't burn hardly any
mental calories the answers Note
Everything the answer is no to
everything except paying off debt right
and so it's you don't have to stop and
think about it yeah there's no no no
it's hard to decide what goes in
retirement what goes on vacation but
then when you back up and you go okay
I'm now now I'm con yes we can do that
but do we want to now that burns some
calories that's right that takes up some
mental anguish I never put that together
before yeah JW is with us JW is uh in
Atlanta hijw how are you
hey Dave just fine how about y'all
better than we deserve how can we help
so me and my wife are having an ASU
right now
JW we got you
I'm about twenty thousand dollars from
having the house paid off excellent
but
now she wants me to sell the house and
buy more expensive house
I can taste it I'm almost there
I'm so close
and I I don't know if you know I talked
to her and was why why is it that we
need a more expensive house and because
that's what everybody else does
and I'm like well I don't want to take
out another loan it's so close to having
it paid off and you know she says well
that's what everybody else does we just
you know you just suck it up that's what
everybody else does and I want to be
like everybody else and I can't
understand I can't figure out how to
convince her to
let's just pay this one off so you've
drug you've drug her Kicking and
Screaming into debt free
yeah
she's gonna try to drag you kicking and
screaming into 3 500 more square feet
oh my God
all right here's what I guarantee you
haven't done yet JW you ready
yep I guarantee you haven't sat down
with her
and said uh honey
I'm exhausted
and I'm scared
I'm scared that when I owe money when we
owe a mortgage if something happens to
me that I'm not going to be able to take
care of you and the kids
yeah yeah absolutely but hold on but
most of us knuckleheaded guys try to
attack this your wife's question with uh
with a math with a math answer
I want you to approach this with a hard
answer for probably the first time with
your heart
okay I'm scared I'm exhausted I need
some time I'm not interested in being
like everybody else I'm interested in
you and me building something magical
that's ours
and maybe that's a bigger house someday
I can't
borrow more money right now
actually yeah yeah okay
but you got you gotta you gotta connect
with her there man because otherwise
it's going to be a tug of war game she
feels like you won the first match and
she is she going she's going to win the
second match you know we've got to
change the uh position from daddy
daughter to husband wife
daddy daddy own a bigger house Daddy
give me a bigger house Daddy
everybody else gets one Daddy
instead instead it's like you and me are
a team
how can we
have the life that we want to build not
other people want to build but the life
that we want to build that includes an
amazing future and us making our
decisions together you get a vote and I
get a vote
not I'm denying you what you want
because I'm a mean old husband that's a
daddy-daughter thing
you're not you're not her daddy
and um yeah absolutely yeah and so you
know that that and that happens in every
marriage uh some more than others some
function all the time that way some
function uh for 20 seconds that way
occasionally or it flips and yeah or it
flips some little boy's got a mind
little boy's got a mommy taking care of
him she does all the bills and he just
works he doesn't have to think about
anything he just brings in the money and
I do all the adult stuff and uh oh God
creepy and so
um yeah that happens all the time though
and so uh
you don't have much of that here but
what John's telling you is come
alongside her and then just pour your
heart out and say this has been a goal
in my life for the first time in my life
I'm free
I can breathe and you're asking me to
let a 300 pound man stand on my chest
again
I just I can't do it
I can't do it and I do want to give you
what you want I want us to have things
that we like together but I also but I
want to do it like grown-ups and so
let's start talking about
getting a bigger house and how we can
get the money together to do that with
cash and might take three years instead
of three months
but the chances of me going into debt
again are precisely zero I'm not doing
it
and um uh I mean Sharon's pretty
acquainted with that conversation I
don't borrow money
for anyone for any reason ever again I'm
through I had my I had my run with that
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
Dr John deloney is my co-host today
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book own your
past change your future he's been in the
writing cave writing a new one we'll be
telling you about that soon
coming out this summer so save your
quarters and nickels you're going to
want to buy it it's going to be that
simple Timothy is next he's in Chicago
hi Timothy welcome to the Ramsey Show
well hello there hey how can we help
great uh so I'm going to get married in
July which is very exciting very awesome
it's good and then you marry you into
fifty thousand dollars of student loans
that's awesome
and uh that's behind us they're gonna
make different choices going forward so
the question here is
it's a relationship question built into
a money situation so I have a
um 100 000 in mutual funds and just a
regular brokerage account so clearly I
could just cash them on way back to debt
my concern is that the loans are on my
future mother-in-law's name the her loan
their Parent PLUS Loan and so I don't
want to be the rich boyfriend that comes
in pays off all the debt and then just
has that status of You Know Rich
boyfriend that
it's gotten on a title to something like
that
hmm
you you don't you want you don't want
the status of you don't want to look
like a snob is that what you're saying
yeah I want
I want trouble with um finances before
and it's tight and hard for them so I
don't want to
I want to guess I prove that I can work
hard and
be smart and it wasn't just all given to
me by my parents or grandparents which
some of this money has so it wasn't all
money that I've earned okay how much of
her student loan debt is her parents
debt
Parent Plus
so all four years are Parent Plus Loans
it's been agreed that me and her will
pay off the last two which is all which
is fifty thousand dollars the bank plus
the first two are like 45 which is right
there so you were not in on the deal
it was agreed originally when they did
this that she would pay
that your fiancee would when she got out
of college you'll pay the first two and
Mom and Dad would pay the second two
there was a grid when they were
finishing High School yeah okay so
that's the deal she made with her mom
and dad
yep okay because she's not legally
obligated but she has a handshake with
them that she's going to do this
uh yes that's exactly right and you're
talking about paying off the portion
that she gave them a handshake and
agreed to pay
right only
yep not the first half okay the other
the other's all mom and dad and it's
still on Mom and Dad after this story is
over right
yep okay yeah that's a no-brainer after
the honeymoon write a check and pay them
off don't pay the mom and dad pay the
loans off
right right and as far as whether you're
a snob or not here's how you don't be a
snob don't be a snob
just don't even bring it up I mean can
you emotionally let this go and not roll
your eyes at them when they're doing
something else stupid because you paid
this off
uh I think that I could it would be
it's my dance
am I on to be okay I could handle it if
you
yeah I I'm confused as to you must have
gotten some smoke somewhere along the
way did you pick up a dinner tab one
time or something and there was kind of
some awkwardness around the table
so we were planning on being
missionaries uh and fundraising our
salary when I asked if I could uh
propose and the father-in-law was not
super thrilled about that and so in the
end I was I told him that I had this
account I was like look if I mentioned
this for two years there's no way we're
gonna like be totally screwed because
now the worst case scenario this could
float us which is what we were planning
on signing into your contract that's all
true we're not going to be missionaries
we're going to have regular jobs so I
think that's kind of
I would recommend this as early as
possible in your marriage that and this
is harder for some people than it is for
others but
at the end of the day you and your wife
have to build a marriage together
and you can't be responsible for the
regulation of the adult emotions in your
life around you so okay what you have is
a debt
you're gonna pay that debt off because
you're a person of character of an
Integrity you worked your butt off to
set yourself up in the situation and you
got some gifts to set yourself yourself
up in the situation great
if he wants to turn and
get offended by it or feel less Superior
whatever he wants to that is his and the
earlier you can learn to not try to
control that the more peaceful your
marriage is going to be moving forward
that makes sense
and expect it expect it if you know it's
coming back then it's coming back cool
and it's just you're gonna be ready
emotionally when that happens and you
just smile and Nod and wander off to the
other room and pour a cup of coffee yeah
because you know it's coming you know
you know it's going to come and then
then you're not the snot the beautiful
thing about this conversation Timothy is
you're self-aware enough and you kind of
felt that rise up in you in that other
conversation that you kind of went oh
that could happen again so John's right
you smelled smoke before and so you're
self-aware enough to go I really need to
steal myself I need to put some Backbone
in myself on this issue because this is
probably coming at me and that's really
the question you were answering that's
right asking and uh John's answering and
so yeah because we know the right thing
to do is to pay the debt off yeah you
need to pay the debt off because that's
it whether it's a legal debt a moral
debt an ethical debt uh which is only
the last two
um it becomes your debt when you get
married and you're going to write a
check when you get home from the
honeymoon and be you know if she had a
car loan you'd pay it off if she had a
student a regular student loan you pay
that off whatever it is and
you're thank God you're aware before
going into this exactly what you're
getting into and you're willing to do
that
and she's worth it and it's just and now
we go forward
and then by the way when you get the flu
she'll make soup
so for in for richer for poorer
and sickness and health
and the old book of common prayer that
you would have heard maybe in the 40s or
50s at a wedding says unto thee all my
worldly Goods I pledge
beautiful old marriage foul seldom used
now and I'm independent culture but I'm
married but I'm independent but I'm
married
[Music]
there's your problem it's not real
there's your sign
yeah Timothy you're doing good I'm
really proud of you I think you're very
self-aware you you kind of you're
observing this you're going I could do
this wrong and how do I not do it wrong
the fact that you're asking the question
is probably a sign you're not going to
do it wrong
uh if you just didn't even know it was
there and you're oblivious that's
probably when you're going to step in it
and put yourself in his shoes not to
excuse a behavior but to give yourself a
little gap between the stimulus and
response
he's got a guy coming in and writing a
check for his daughter that he couldn't
write
that's gonna hurt a little bit it's
gonna hurt a little bit and I can
imagine that stinging a little bit and
so so be it I get it it's it's silly
it's inappropriate but I get it it's
kind of interesting too that he was
questioning their financial plan oh he's
broke it's incredible but that's that's
that's I mean that's where that's where
the the biggest jeers come from the
cheap seats right
that's where the complainers come throw
the peanuts only from the cheap seats
exactly oh this is how it works man I'm
telling you so yeah that um
it's it's a sweet Spirit you've got on
this Timothy I think you're going to be
just fine I think you're doing a good
thing and um thank God it's not 500 000.
you know or more likely the way I
usually hear this call is I don't have
that money and father-in-law is asking
for the check right now yeah where's my
money yeah well good luck with that I
don't have it I didn't do this dude you
did so now I can write that check yeah
yeah that's that's and so it becomes
this push thing this push and pull and
uh this is why let me tell you student
loans are evil Parent Plus Loans
are straight from the pit of Hell
because
the parent is borrowing the money for
the kid to go to school and then there's
all these side deals or these unsaid
unmet expectations or there's a deal and
then suddenly you get a nice job out of
college and then surely you're going to
change the video yeah I mean look at him
he makes all this money how to pick it
up I told him I'd pay it but I mean look
at that gym and it's just these things
have not only the problems and the
weight of a student loan but they have
the ability to drive wedges in families
as well right and in relationships it's
straight up from the pit of Hell this
student loan thing is man it hey
Congress
stop making them
you're screwing up a whole generation or
two stop it
there's nothing good coming out of this
they've only got a degree in left-handed
puppetry stop it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author and Ramsay personality the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Chris is in
Canada hi Chris welcome to the Ramsay
show
all right how are you guys doing better
than we deserve how can we help
um I just had a question
in the long term long time listener uh I
never really had
everything the other day Okay your
phone's cutting out man speak directly
into your phone
okay how's that much better thank you
yeah my uh my wife got a message from
her parents staying with the they're
going on rent for a couple of months or
uh fixing to be kicked out
um
they're not asking us to help but I mean
they've asked us a whole bunch of times
to help us build and to pay things and
we're just they're not great with their
money and they don't make a whole lot of
it they don't work a lot so we just
don't really know what to do to help
them
how old are you
okay
30.
30 yeah yeah and how long you been
married
two years been together 10 years yeah so
these people are in their 50s
year round yeah mid 50s almost late yeah
okay do you even have the ability to
help
is this a frustration question or is
this a
math problem question
uh we're going through the baby steps
ourselves we're paying off our own debt
so I mean we don't have the financial
ability to help all that much but
um we do have a house of our own that we
can bring them into but I mean it'll be
really tight if the two of them it's her
younger sister she's got two kids I got
two dogs
so it would be really tight and I mean
we wouldn't really want the ramp or a
little weird thing so younger sister has
two kids and she lives with them also
yeah she's about like 20 24 25. is she
working today no
so this isn't a matter of helping out
this is a matter of transferring
complete dysfunction this is a mess
um it is
yeah yeah they don't the the one the
father Works more mainly and then he
works for the construction company and
he's good at his job when he when he has
work but I mean he's working very little
um
yeah he doesn't work much the daughter
doesn't work at all and Mama doesn't
work at all there's kids and dogs all
over the place and they don't pay their
bills
uh yeah it's hard for them no it's hard
for them because they don't work
yeah I mean I don't I don't know where
my wife got to work ethic from but she
worked two jobs
I don't either because these people
don't work
sometimes people grow up in a situation
and they say not never again and maybe
that's your wife
yeah yeah because she kind of grew up in
here a little bit so Tim one of the most
painful things that we do as an adult
is we watch people that we love
friends or family
do stupid things
and misbehave
and there's nothing we can do about it
and we hurt for them more than they
heard for themselves
it's very hard
yeah when uh when we were speaking to
her mother she kind of seeing a little
bit cool common collected and working on
over here like are you are you relaxed
right now like you can't pay your bills
you're kind of struggling you're
thinking being kicked out like I think
that's an important thing for you to
notice about yourself you can't care
more about them than they do about
themselves
yeah yeah I get that they're not
children
yeah I'm sorry I hate this it's not
harsh but here's the thing if you gave
them ten thousand dollars
and they got completely current
in one year they're going to be right
back here again aren't they
the conversation
we said we could win the lottery
tomorrow and we can give them a house
and 500 000 for any money but I mean
they've come back eventually yeah
yeah and so there's no amount there's no
amount of funding
help that's going to actually help
until they change
would you agree with that
I agree so throwing money at them is
uh almost hurtful because it's kind of
like you're giving a drunk a drink
we call that enabling we call that
enabling
right go and get a job you know I really
wouldn't say anything to them about them
I would just talk about what you guys
are doing and say you know we we figured
out if we work a lot that we have more
money
we figured out that if we live on a
budget and control our spending very
carefully that we don't have as much
stress because we're never behind and I
would make statements about yourself and
then if they ever go wow I'd be cool to
do that I said I would be honored to
show you how to do that
I'd be honored to work with you and
Coach you on how to do that I'll be your
biggest cheerleader but I'm not ever
giving you another dime again
because money doesn't help them Tim
they need a new set of information
plugged into their computer
yeah their program is corrupted
I remember when I was in college I had
an opportunity to leave school and go do
something and the guy was we're back and
forth and I was like dude am I dropping
out of college is stupid
um and it was a cool opportunity but I'm
not going to leave school and he told me
something that has stuck with me forever
even though I ended up finishing school
and all that
he said the people who are successful
don't have a backup plan and I said why
Amigos because they'll use it
and that was silly Instagram advice
before there was Instagram but there's
something to
until your father-in-law realizes
there's no there's no there's no
superhero coming this time
I'm just gonna have to stay at work and
make more money until your sister
realizes that there isn't just some
money doesn't fall out of the clouds to
help her two little babies who are
desperate need of somebody giving them
some structure and some support
um
until there's continues to be a backup
plan they're going to continue to use I
mean they're going to continue using
that back anyway so um if they come to
me for help I would say here's what I'm
willing to do I'm willing to lay out a
detailed game plan and I'm willing to
cheer you on as you go do it and if you
go do everything on there I may surprise
you with some other help but in the
meantime the help I'm going to give you
is information to reprogram how you're
doing life because your life sucks
you're not having fun that's only if
they ask because people I don't answer
questions that people don't ask anymore
I sit here all day and answer questions
on the radio but you asked so I'll
answer it but my friends and family that
come into my life doing stupid stuff I
just look at them and go get a cup of
coffee
and nothing I can do but if you ask huh
don't ask don't ask because I'll tell
you because I love you so much I'll
guide you out of this and I'll show you
the the hard answers to the questions
work hard you're gonna have a callus
you're gonna be tired
OT over time is going to be a big part
of your life and you're going to pile up
so much cash that you keep the wolf away
from your door and we're going to jack
the 24 year old up and get her a life
that's sustainable living with Mom and
Daddy where their two kids is not a plan
of the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're a pastor
listening today
we know that you've had a hard few years
you've got long hours
Church attendance is down
church is still trying to come back
after covet in many cases and all while
trying to keep your own house running
you've had to take care of so much and
we want to take care of you
you deserve a safe space to talk about
the hard things you're dealing with
especially money
so we created a free
pastors only
version of Financial Peace University
over six weeks you'll learn with pastors
from all over the country how to get out
of debt and build wealth how to get
control of your money with a budget out
of work with your spouse if you have one
and even how to retire with confidence
it's all free and this class is led by
folks on our team who understand
pastors many of them are former pastors
and they have a heart for you
so join our free pastors only Financial
Peace University
by visiting ramseysolutions.com pastor
ramseysolutions.com
slash Pastor today's question of the day
comes from Shelley in the baby steps
millionaires community on Facebook John
my mother is always giving me money that
I don't ask for but I know she has bad
spending habits what would you do about
this situation
foreign
I've never had this happen to me
personally this is a new one this is a
new one
um
I would probably do one of two things
the passive part of me would probably
take this money and put it into an
account and let it just sit because
there's going to be a day that she comes
and asks for it back
um the more the the last four or five
years six or seven years John would tell
my mom hey mom I'm really working hard
to build a life uh with my wife our own
life and so
um I appreciate your gift I'm really
grateful for it but we want to make it
go at this on our own and so uh please
feel free to give that money to my
brother my sister whoever else yeah as
gentle as I can the problem has not
heard the problem is me don't bring up
the fact that she's too broke to give
nope wouldn't even go there
wouldn't even go there I would just say
you know I appreciate this and you're so
sweet
um a I don't need it and B I'm trying to
practice
the discipline of living on my own and
it would be helpful to me if you would
give this to someone else my promise is
if I ever get desperate enough I'll call
you I won't go hungry I promise Mom and
you're so sweet and thank you thank you
but um I can't accept this anymore
because I'm trying to work on me yeah
and just turn turn the whole thing back
on yourself and say yeah yeah there's a
the other one that comes up is um and
I've heard this one a bunch of times
over the years is uh mom and dad are
broke but mom keeps buying my kids toys
on and trips and whatever grandparents
stuff Disney grandparents stuff on
credit cards and making making Mom and
Dad worse
how do I stop her from doing that and
it's a similar conversation on only this
one's even harder but it's like Mom
we're trying to limit what the kids are
getting and
um you know uh so we you just can't do
this anymore uh you've got to stop
you're gonna have to check with me
before you buy anything else yeah and um
and then again there's no it it very
seldom is positive to shame them and go
you're too broke to do this stop it that
doesn't work although that's a true
statement but
and it's tempting to say that but it's
really not profitable Devante is with us
in Minneapolis if I can push the button
there he is hey Devante how are you
hey how you doing I'm doing well good
how can I help
um well and the better interest is just
getting the question out there uh I
guess I'll just say a question you guys
can rip into me after that uh the
question I have is that I have a car or
I have about fifty thousand dollars in
debt the car is a little over half of
that at about 27.
um 19 interest rate I'm trying to get
out and then a follow-up question is
just if I'm gazelle intense enough uh
based on how much I'm working and and
the things I'm doing to me you owe 27
000 on a car at 19 percent
yeah yes okay what's the car worth
uh fourteen thousand
uh
uh did you roll negative equity from
another deal into this one
uh no I didn't um okay you're looking at
the wrong number then because a 19 loan
is a sub Prime loan translation they
screwed you okay or you screwed Yourself
by signing up for this and they have a
different calculation on those loans
when you ask for the ballots they use a
total of all payments a top number
to give you the loan balance that is not
the payoff
so your payoff is unlikely to be 27 not
with a fourteen thousand dollar value
how long ago did you buy the car
this is about a year ago just under yeah
what'd you pay for the car
thus far I've paid about 700. no no
honey what was the price of the car when
you signed the paperwork the total price
of the car not the financing what was
the price of the car
oh I guess I don't know the answer to
that it was 27 on the the only
uh overall price that came out was 27 so
I thought that was the the value
well I mean it's a car's worth 14 honey
you surely didn't pay 27.40 a year ago
unless you went to one of those it was a
third party it was a third party dealer
um I was just desperate trying to get
into something low credit and that's
what they gave me I don't know even
those guys don't do that
okay so I really think that you probably
actually paid 17 or 18 for the car and
your total of payments is 27. so you
have a a finance company you're paying
this money to right
yes okay call them and ask them for what
the payoff is if I bring a check today
and pay it off
and they're going to tell you more like
20. okay or 18 or something like that
that's the number you're going to get
um
and uh and you obviously don't have any
money right
uh no I've I've since recovered my
situation so I do how much do you have
I'm sorry no uh currently speaking no I
don't have a
and savings oh you don't have any money
okay so I was right all right what do
you make
um 100 and anywhere between 113 130
depend
s but then how long have you been doing
that
um four months why don't you have any
money
I've been putting everything to debt
okay all right I want you to stop
putting it to debt because I want this
car to get sold
okay I want you to stop putting it to
Dad I want you to save up enough to sell
the car for 14 and put seven thousand
with it and sell the car because it's
gonna be 20 21 18 something like that
payoff then I want you to go get a two
thousand dollar car and pay cash for it
this car needs to go bye-bye it's bad
juju bad car
I agree and uh there's gonna be a sense
dude that you're taking 7 000 or 10 000
whatever that final payoff is and
putting it in your backyard and just
lighting it on fire and you are and you
know you already did that now all we're
doing is admitting it yeah we're just
yeah and it's gonna hurt and uh it's
it's gonna be a good SCAR or tattoo for
you to never do this again ever yeah and
so yeah desperation makes us do crazy
things man everything you did when you
went on the car lot a hundred percent of
your moves were wrong
you went on the car lot wrong move you
bought a car you never looked at what
it's valued at you have no idea what it
was you just said if I sign here I can
drive it off yes and you signed whatever
they put in front of you you never
looked at it this is the recipe for
getting screwed and if you do it again
you're gonna screw it again if you do it
again you're gonna get screwed again
yeah this is how it works this is how
these people exist in these rip-off car
situations uh and so they feed on the
desperation and the immaturity of people
and so uh the next time this comes up
you need to step back breathe a little
bit and think okay where can I get a
thousand dollar car and like how where
can I get a thousand dollars and let's
get a uh a garage sale car car you
bought a garage sale and drive it around
a little bit and if it goes bad after a
month or two it was still cheaper than
your payments
and go get you another one I mean these
are disposable cars like disposable
phones when you're doing a thousand
dollar car compared to what you're
driving but yeah this thing is uh it's a
weight around your neck it's uh shaming
to you every time you get in it every
time you write the check it's a rip-off
there's nothing good coming out of it I
would do everything I could to get rid
of it as soon as possible
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
I'm Dave Ramsey your host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Tim is in Chicago hey Tim how are
you
hey I'm doing well how you guys doing
better than I deserve how can we help
uh so my wife and I are considering
buying our first home in the next year
or two cool we've got a down payment set
aside the savings account but we also
have a substantial amount of money in
Investments that are not retirement
Investments and we're trying to decide
if we should sell some or all of those
and put it towards the down payment so
we just don't know how to decide if
that's a good decision or not
well the shortest distance between Where
You Are
and wealth uh being a millionaire and
Beyond uh the first two things that end
up happening uh in all the data that we
have on millionaires that we've
collected over 30 years uh the first two
things that happen are a paid for home
and a large gradually built up 401K Roth
IRA retirement plan okay that leads me
to unto that confirms what we've been
teaching all these years that your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and when you don't tie up your
income with debt payments you can use
your income to build wealth translation
I'm going to pay off my house as fast as
I can I'm gonna put as much down on my
house as I can without cashing any
retirement how much is in your
non-retirement that you said that's
substantial
uh it's about three hundred thousand
dollars why to go man good for you thank
you and how much down payment uh fund
have you saved
oh we've got about 130 000 in cash okay
and do you have an emergency fund beyond
that yes we have we actually have 50 000
set aside some of that would be for
maybe a car purchase in the next maybe
four or five years and the rest is uh
actual emergency fund like six months of
expenses so if I'm doing my math right
you have four hundred and thirty
thousand dollars you could put down what
is the price range of home you're
thinking of
I mean we're looking at no more than
five hundred thousand perfect and your
household income is what
uh two hundred thousand excellent and so
you've got one debt to pay off then
which is a seventy thousand dollar debt
you're a hundred percent debt free uh
you'll be sitting in a paid for half a
million dollar by then maybe six hundred
thousand dollar house and you make 200
000 a year and how old are you
uh we're 33. wow wow man and uh how much
is in your retirement accounts
oh it's got about 270 total so your net
worth at that point would be somewhere
in the neighborhood of 870 770 somewhere
in there and uh putting you at a being a
millionaire by the time you're 35 fairly
easy right
uh I think so yeah yeah that's pretty
incredible Tim well done
okay yeah thank you but here's the thing
here's the thing if you're not if that's
what normal people will run up a big
mortgage and then just run their
Investments okay but normal's broke and
the think about I just want you to kind
of sit with your wife with no television
on
and feel what just let the feeling run
over your body what it would feel like
to be in a paid for
five hundred thousand dollar house
three hundred thousand dollars in my
401k fifty thousand in my savings
account
I'm 32 years old
man
yeah sounds pretty good it feels pretty
peaceful doesn't it
and the sidebar of that is that peace
causes your relationships to be
different causes your health to be
different causes you to be better at
work uh more have a more of a tendency
to walk away from toxic things at work
and go do something else if the people
that are misbehaving and over the scope
of 10 years there's some uh
non-mathematical things that cause you
to prosper as you were explaining that
Dave I was thinking the biggest fight
they would have if the air conditioner
went out is who's calling the AC company
that would be the fight yeah we're so
chilled we're so Peach chilled that's
funny we're so chilled out we're so
peaceful that both of us forgot to call
you called the roofer I'm not calling
you call the roofer that's the fight not
no how are we gonna eat no and this
where are we going on vacation yeah but
you know a buddy of mine years ago I was
working for this guy who's a real
motivational guy he's a he was a fun guy
and he uh it stuck with me he said you
know I just want to make enough money
and I can go to a restaurant and I can
read the menu left to right
instead of starting with the price yeah
it's amazing I'm just going to pick out
what I want and then I'm going to notice
what the price was and
um
it's not like wow you know yeah I went
with this guy who's a a billionaire on a
trip a while back and we were uh in this
Resort town and we go to this fancy
fancy restaurant and uh there's a big
big Steakhouse deal and so they've got
this uh
wagyu on the menu uh that is like from
an award-winning cow I mean this is not
just wagyu this is this is a blue ribbon
wow or some kind of crap I don't know
what it is it sleeps on a mattress yeah
but it's like I don't know we get this
little bitty piece of steak sliced real
thin that each of us can share a taste
of and it was a hundred and like ten
dollars right for this and we're looking
at it going
that's fun
it was really it was very it was very
good and of course there was no way it's
worth 110 right or 140 or whatever the
crap he paid for it but he goes I've
just never done anything like this
before and we're going to do it right
now and so we ordered three of them for
the table there's a bunch of guys
sitting there and we're all sitting
there eating Bessie the win
award-winning wagyu
whatever she was or he was right I don't
know and um
but it's just that that's I it doesn't
matter if you do that when you got a
billion dollars like that guy right he
bought him for the whole table so what
there was remember that show uh uh
American Choppers they made those
awesome yeah and it was the it was the
Father's son and they're always
bickering at each other
I remember being younger I was watching
that show and they were in a huge fight
and one of them storms outside and
getting the car to drive off and he hits
the wrong gear and he backs up and hits
something and screws up the bumper and
his son comes out to help and they're
all mad and the son says I can fix that
and he puts a chain around it to pop it
back out this the bumper
and he floors it and just rips the whole
bumper off and they start dying laughing
and I remember sitting there thinking I
want that much money
or I can do that solvent argue with my
old man I could wreck his car and we'll
both think it's hilarious I remember
that launching my head like I want that
much money
yeah well that was a reality show that
they they really didn't do that let me
live in my in my little happy world
you're living the reality show okay uh
yeah but that there is a thing to that
there's a um you get it uh one of the
values of money is that you can do some
things generosity wise uh for other
people you can buy the whole table
especially the wagyu whatever you can do
the uh you can rip the bumper off for
some I mean I don't know whatever it is
you can do stuff and it um
it's it's such a small percentage of the
overall picture that it doesn't matter
and so you do it all with a level of
Peace rather than a level of looking
over your shoulders see who's seeing you
do it you don't have to have an
Instagram moment right because you don't
care and I remember being a new
professional and uh there's a woman a
couple of people ahead of me in the
grocery line and it was that you just
see that fear like I forgot my money I
don't have it
and I didn't I didn't have it and I
remember thinking this doesn't happen
again John next time I see this next
time I'm going to be okay I'm going to
be in a place where I can help her out
yeah and that's just that stuck with me
all these years man yeah yeah and I I've
done giving things I don't remember
those the ones I remember was when I
wasn't ready yeah yeah and they're
sticking you they stick in your crawl
you know you can't get rid of that one
so that's the benefit of this stuff so
man he's done such a great job he has
done such a great job he's gonna you
know and here's the thing if you're a
millionaire when you're 35 do you know
what you are when you're 65 ooh baby
uh wow so here's your rule of thumb okay
a lump sum invested in good mutual funds
if it averaged only 10 percent Which is
less than the market
if it ever it's only ten percent that
lump sum doubles about every seven years
so a million in seven years if you got
it when you're 35 when you're 42 it's
two
okay when you're 49 it's four
when you're 56 it's eight
you want me to keep going yeah it's a
lot and that's if he adds nothing to it
no more money yeah adds nothing to it
and we know that's not happening tens of
millions of dollars are some of your
fingertips if you just get your act
together this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today Philippians 2 13 for
it is God who works in you both to Will
and to work for his good pleasure
Jesse Owens 1936 Olympic four-time gold
medalist said the battles that count
aren't the ones for gold medals the
struggles within yourself
the invisible
inevitable battles inside all of us
that's where it's at
a way to go Roxanne's with us Roxanne's
in Anaheim California hi Roxanne welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi there thank you for taking my call my
pleasure I'm a bit nervous
so it's part of my well listen Roxanne I
almost sang your name does that happen
all the time
yeah take a shot every time you say my
name huh I didn't I almost did and I did
that happen people used to call me
deloney bologna all the time growing up
and so I didn't want to contribute to
the madness of your life so there you go
don't be nervous
um thank you okay I've got a few things
going on I am I've got about 50 000 in
credit card debt
uh
I'm about seventeen thousand dollars
with a business loan I try to start a
small business and I have no customers
right now so I have no money coming in
so now I'm looking for work
um I'm starting to get I'm six months
behind on my business loan I'm late on
my credit card and I don't know where to
go
um do I take my 401k out to pay these
this this debt
because of the interest rates are just
killing me do I take out a personal loan
do I write my credit card companies uh
I'm sure whatever is going to take me a
few months to catch up just to my own
personal debt uh so hi yeah what do I do
scary isn't it
um yeah are you single
I am married
okay what does he make
uh pretty good money he makes about uh
two hundred thousand
a year so how long have you guys been
married
[Music]
well you're about 19 years late on
combining your finances yeah yeah
yes we are yeah because you know my wife
is not going to be late on things when I
make 200 000 a year I'm married to her
for better for worse
for richer for poor you're not his
roommate you're his wife
right
so what is he saying about all what's he
saying about your debt being behind and
you're not having a job
[Music]
um
kind of just ignoring it pretending like
it's not happening because I I always
have a way to figure it out Roxanne does
he know how bad it is
um not really no it's time for you to
come clean
and it's gonna be a moment of sadness
and shame and there's probably going to
be some other Ripple effects because
there's probably been some other stuff
over the 20 years that y'all haven't
told each other but you got to come
clean
and together together we have about a
hundred thousand dollars in IRS debt so
I we have been keeping our financials
separate
um to get together you have a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in debt and
he makes 200 000 and you're getting
ready to get a job and start making
money so you're gonna have 300 000 or
whatever coming into this house and
you're going to clean up that 150 000 in
debt in about a year and a half if you
will finally combine your finances and
quit acting like roommates
okay and just say together we can do
anything separately we suck
yeah
but that involves you not having so much
pride I'll clean up my own mess or him
not being a jerk saying you clean up
your own mess uh but you guys are
missing out on some of the best parts of
marriage because you're stiff arming
each other
yeah yeah I definitely Pride as takes
place in there because I've worked my
whole life and oh well you're not it's
not that you're not of value it's not
that you're not of value it's not that
you need a keeper that's not the point
the point is it's for better for worse
and sickness and health if you got
cancer he's supposed to take care of you
and you didn't do anything wrong there
okay I mean you may have made some
mistakes with money uh but welcome to
being a human walking around in America
if you're if you made mistakes with
money you're over 12. so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna be in Anaheim
doing a a Building Wealth event on May
the 5th and
um I think it's the fifth or some may
something like that and um no it's right
before that for a second or so yeah okay
or early May and uh we're gonna have
Austin pick up and he's going to give
him a second he's going to pick up and
give you two VIP tickets for you and
your husband that means that I'm going
to get to meet you we'll take a picture
with you but you're going to be there
for the Building Wealth live event I'm
also going to give you Financial Peace
University but you have to do it
together Roxanne
Now's the Time Now's the Time okay all
this stuff of I can stand on my own or
uh or he doesn't need to help or he
thinks he's too cool to help or whatever
the is in this chemistry of this
conversation has got to be wiped clean
and your two newlyweds smiling and
looking at the rest of your life
together
and going we're going to combine
everything and we're going to take on
the world and the IRS and we're going to
win on both fronts so you can do this
hold on Austin's going to pick a pick up
and get you into all of that Susan's in
Youngstown Ohio hi Susan welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi thanks for taking my call
sure how can I help well my mother
passed away in October of last year my
brother was the executor of her estate
and his name was on her checking
accounts so the money was divided
between the siblings that was into
checking accounts now since it since he
could write the checks and it is it
considered an inheritance or a gift
should be an inheritance
it's her money in the account just
because his name was on the account
doesn't change it okay because my
account yeah my accountants Talent is
telling me I don't have to pay an
inheritance tax well there's not an
inheritance tax but the only question is
is there a gift tax and there's no
inheritance tax unless she had a net
worth of over 20 million dollars no but
she's telling me that I'm going to have
to pay income on that money no it's not
income if you need a new accountant okay
no there's absolutely not taxable
inheritance is not a taxable event
period okay period period I mean I mean
you can get an inherited IRA and that
can be taxable but this is just a
checking account there was your mom's
cash the executor of the state
distributed part of the estate by
writing checks out that is not a taxable
event period I'm not a tax expert but
I'm right
okay you usually are Dave no sometimes
I'm not on taxes but this one I do know
okay this one I do know she it's just a
matter of how they nuance and how they
couch it if she decides she wants it to
be a gift then you know then you've got
a gift tax if it's an inheritance
there's not an inheritance tax and so
the executor of the estate is
liquidating the estate happened to have
his name on the checking account already
which made it easy to do mechanically
tactically but it doesn't change the
legality the money was not his the money
was moms and he as the executor
distributed it to according to the will
according to her wishes to The Heirs and
that is not a taxable event
period
so um you know you may need a different
accountant or you may need to put some
different documentation in the file you
may need a letter from your brother as
the executive of the state this money
was distributed I I was acting as the
executor of the estate I'm not your
brother giving you a gift
I'm acting as the executor of the estate
and I am Distributing this money as a
distribution from the estate by
liquidating the checking account that's
simple and then then it is simply not
taxable inherited money is not taxable
yet but it's not right now
wow
uh we'll say that conversation for
another day Dave I'm just that puts this
one in the books I love it Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality my co-host
this hour I am Dave Ramsey your host
thanks to James to Ben to Austin in the
booth Zach the guys the booth boys that
do this work we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]